And that was what the ordered
part of our specification for
sort was all about.
Now let's look at the second part which
had to do with whether the elements
were the same in the output
as they were in the input.
So we're going to begin the same way
we did before and I'd like you, Jared,
see if you can state in
English what it means for
two vectors X and
Y to have the same elements.
And we're going to call this function
that we're defining same elements as.
>> Okay.
Do we need to start by
writing a signature and
going through this whole process.
>> That's the process, yes.
>> So for this function,
we will take two vectors.
A vector X.
Oh, before I forget.
>> Go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> And finish what you got.
>> All right.
I've noticed the flaw, but
we will be taking two vectors.
We'll take a vector X and a vector Y,
and a comparison will happen.
We can assume, and it will return a
boolean value representing whether they
have the same elements or not.
>> And
what did you label your boolean result?
>> As Y, which is the same,
we've already assigned that.
>> Okay, so obviously,
this is actually a legitimate signature,
well, I shouldn't say it's legitimate.
It's a syntactically correct signature,
but it's not meaningful because we're
using the same value,
the same letter in two different places.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, as I said before,
the actual letter that we use
doesn't make any difference,
as long as we consistently use it.
So we could say here,
bool Y, we could say bool Z.
As long as it's different than
those input names that we used.